so we already knew last week about these
private email accounts that were used
individually by Jared Kushner Donald
Trump's son-in-law and Ivanka Trump
Donald Trump's daughter both of whom
have roles in the White House last week
we learned that son-in-law Jared Kushner
had been using private email actually
since December of 2016
specifically for White House related
work we also learned last week the day
after that Ivanka Trump Donald Trump's
daughter and sort of high-powered
adviser I think that's that's a pretty
accurate assessment she also has been
using personal email accounts for
government work now there's been a huge
effort to try to downplay it all
including with Jared Kushner there's a
statement we read last week which I'll
read for you again today from Jared
Kushner's attorney where Abe Lowell said
Mr Kushner uses his White House email
address to conduct White House business
fewer than 100 emails from January
through August were either sent to or
returned by mich Mr Kushner to
colleagues in the White House from his
personal email account these usually
forwarded news articles or political
commentary and most often occurred when
someone initiating the exchange by
sending an email to his personal rather
than his White House address now let's
keep that up just for a second because
there's a couple words I want to point
out which are weasel words right these
usually forwarded news articles and you
also have to look at the word most often
occurred those make the statement
effectively meaningless in communicating
what Kushner's lawyer wants to
communicate so that's what we knew up
until yesterday now we've learned of a
third previously unreported personal
email account for Jared and Ivanka Trump
they had their own private email domain
a family domain hundreds of emails were
sent to it since January from White
House email addresses and the documents
sent include non-public travel documents
I'll get back to that in a second
internal schedules official White House
materials and again these were largely
from White House accounts sometimes from
other private accounts and by the way
not only did Jared and Ivanka both
access to this account so did the staff
of their house why is that relevant
non-public travel schedules their
household staff Republicans used to
regularly happily remind everybody that
when it came to Hillary's emails there
were non-public travel documents which
are considered classified that were
being sent around now we have Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump's staff reading
non-public schedules on their private
email account but I guess it's only bad
when Hillary does it right how does
Jared Kushner still have a job or at
least a security clearance because this
proves to us that it was never actually
about Hillary Clinton's emails it was a
smear campaign period and parts of this
are actually worse than what Hillary
Clinton did for example Hillary Clinton
didn't send classified information to
her private email address specifically
to share it with her staff who might not
have had security clearances that's
what's happening with this email
belonging to Jared and Ivanka Trump they
shared access to that email address with
the staff of their home and documents
that are not supposed to be public were
readily accessible by the staff of their
house this is not a big deal because of
the act itself it's a big deal because
Republicans were so successfully able to
turn this into something that was very
damaging to Hillary Clinton and they all
do it
whereas congressman jason Chaffetz
calling for an investigation or leading
an investigation wait a second Chaffetz
did this himself one of many Republicans
who did it vice president Mike Pence had
an AOL account Kris Kobach used one
while he was on Donald Trump's voter
suppression commission it is a very very
long list there should be a German word
for this level of hypocrisy we know the
word schadenfreude which is pleasure
derived by someone for another's
misfortune the word hypocrisy or double
standard is not a strong enough word
here may I I'm not good at German I
don't speak German but maybe there is a
German word for this level of hypocrisy
in double standards the exact thing that
are according to them disqualified
Hillary Clinton from being President of
the United States is something they all
were doing and continue to do even to
this day discuss this with us on our
reddit discussion forum david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t today's episode is
made possible in part by blueSky a
binary there are millions of forex
traders around the world and 80% of them
lose money and I actually have been
dabbling in forex trading since I was
like 16 years old and I've lost some
money doing it and usually when people
lose money in this it is because they
either lack the appropriate knowledge
they might be relying on others auto
traders or other traders they follow
instead of themselves sometimes people
get emotional or take bigger risks than
they should or not understand or follow
proper money management rules and blue
sky binaries education course sort of
helps to mitigate every single one of
those risk factors they're a leading
financial education and tech company
focused on forex they've got senior
trading traders with real trading
experience offering a structured and
self-paced course that you can take
video on-demand online tests one on one
education sessions and access to their
community of traders are all part of
that course david pakman show viewers
and listeners can register right now to
get a free one-week trial at blue sky
binary.com slash david that includes
access to their training platform and a
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics if you want to continue after
that it's $99.99 a month you can stop or
resume at any time once again that's
blue sky binary.com /d AV ID